let's see where do we want to go next
why don't we talk to let's talk to Sam
we haven't heard from Sam for a while
what's going on Sam what's new with you
we can although I have a few guesses as
to maybe some of the different things
going on with your connection I can't
tell what it is but what's going on - hi
baby now yes I got it gave it I have a
question with a gerbil snarl as a
foreign leader he might be a lot of
words I can't say on the air but do you
think it's worth trading with him as a
foreign leader because he wants to be
more friendly with the United States how
do you feel about that do you mean
trading Trump for ball so narrow or do
you mean just the US and I'm Raziel like
open up free trade agreement free trade
agreements and whatnot he wants to be
friendlier with the United States the
previous president yeah I have no
problem again so listen that this is a
big thing that now a lot of
right-wingers are jumping on which is we
should want to be friendly with
everybody let's be friendly with Putin
let's be friendly with Kim jong-un and
all of that that's totally fine the
problem isn't friendliness the problem
is when our president just gets himself
taken advantage of and he doesn't even
realize it because he's so ignorant
which is I think what's happening with
Putin and what's happening with Kim
jong-un so I have no like a priori
opposition to getting more involved
economically with Brazil assuming that
it's being done in a way that you know
to call something mutually beneficial if
you have a zero-sum view on a lot of
these issues something can't be mutually
beneficial
the problem is I just don't trust Trump
to not get himself taken advantage of
and not even realize it which is the
theme palette hello
all right Sam's gone weird
okay Sam Walt great to hear from you
albeit briefly